Tarak owlusa seeks spousal support from  ex Kristina in his divorce petition a  new court documents obtained by et the  flipper flop star is requesting  financial support from his estranged  wife and requesting that Kristina pay  his attorneys fees we're constantly on  the move this is what we do but family  always comes first  et confirmed Monday Tareq filed for  divorce from Kristina after seven years  of marriage the couple that works  together apparently doesn't stay  together flipping houses is our passion  despite their differences Tareq and  Kristina have previously said they are  still committed to filming their TV  series together and co-parenting their  two kids daughter Taylor and son Brayden